community health workers go house to
house trying to convince people to get
vaccinated against
Cola good good it's the first
immunization campaign in Zimbabwe since
the current outbreak began in February
last year Cecilia rero has agreed to
take the drug protecting myself is very
important if I get sick hopefully I will
recover quickly Health officials say
they have secured more than than 2
million doses of the oral cholera
vaccine from the United Nations a global
shortage means they have to be rationed
Zimbabwe has only received about 900,000
doses for this campaign only one dose
will be given as opposed to the usual
two doses one dose will protect the
individual for at least 6 months as
opposed to two doses which is a
protection of about above 3 years kadana
a highdensity suburb in the capital
Harare is one of the worst affected
neighborhoods eratic supplies of Clean
Water uncollected garbage and raw sewage
flowing in the streets have increased
infections there's a fou stench in the
neighborhood people who live on the
street say it's been like this for years
and some of them are now used to it they
cope by keeping their windows and door
[Music]
shut there are outbreaks in several
other African countries experts say if
water and sanitation issues in urban
centers aren't addressed urgently
vaccines are only a temporary solution
to a long-term health problem haruta
aler make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer